Let's be real.
You're gonna want to do something cute and special for Christmas.
Like, we all wanna do this basket
if you're already gonna buy it for laundry.
This is my plan for Christmas.
Like, I'm going to just fill it with all, like,
little Christmas gifts. The ones that aren't the big fucking deal,
the ones that aren't like,
holy shit, but, like,
their gifts. Just to make it, like,
all, like,
cute and organized. Or, like,
she's saying, this could be the, like,
advent calendar, you know,
you pull out a book or you pull out a box.
This little basket, I just fucking love it.
It's just so cute and pretty.
To put other shit in and make it look like,
Ho, ho, ho,
like, what a Merry Christmas.